we are moving forward into statistical
analysis and things are really really
the rubbers really gonna hit the road
I'm very excited about this part of the
course because it's so immensely useful
and practical now this idea of
correlation is probably a word i hope
you've heard before like even in like
the news or when there's a you know an
election happening and people are trying
to convince you of something it's
something you very briefly described in
class before which is why i'm going to
jump straight in to the first question
every statistical measure you know about
answers a question it tells you
something let me give you an example
main mode median they all roughly tell
you they all roughly answer the same
question about set of scores well what
did they tell you mean motor minyan yeah
where's the where's the middle of this
data roughly where's the center right
they each answer it in a different way
what about things like say standard
deviation variance range in 2/4 what do
these tell you yeah how far things
spread out right so we call them
measures of central tendency and then
measures have spread right now
correlation also answers a question but
it's quite a different one it's a
question that only is relevant in
bivariate data as the name suggests
bivariate means you've got two things or
perhaps more but we're only going to
particularly look at two things that
you're interested in two variables
bivariate how much do you remember about
the very brief conversation you have
with missus these earlier
what does correlation or what could
correlation tell you what do you reckon
sorry
the example of Nicolas Cage movies now
it's almost like I planned this now this
is interesting because it's actually a
counter example a counter example that
this is an example of what it's not so
we'll come to this in a second
what's correlations supposed to tell you
because this is what it does until
you're actually going the second
question Jovie like the name suggests
it's about how are two things connected
to each other what does one variable one
score like how does it show a connection
to something else how these Co related
okay now this is a famous counter
example because we're sort of getting to
the second question right what
correlation tells you is when you've got
two variables how closely are they
connected but what it doesn't tell you
what correlation doesn't tell you is
that one thing causes another does that
make sense so that's why we say
correlation this is a very sort of
famous and important phrase that
correlation does not equal causation
right so hopefully this is something you
can just say instinctively but we want
to sort of drill a bit further into well
you know okay we get this is what it
doesn't tell us what cannon right now if
you open up those little booklets that
you've got there go to exercise two I
think it is which is pretty close to the
front the exercise headings are not that
big so you have to sort of hunt it down
a little bit you will see things like
this right so we're looking at scatter
graphs because scatter graphs are
generally the tool of choice when you
want to represent not one variable but
two right so you have one axis to one
variable other axis for the other and
then we're comparing right so we've got
two categories when you're looking at
bivariate data two categories of
correlation one is positive and one is
negative let's just quickly describe
each one
you have a look at the graph right you
can start with that very first one in
the top left well you have a positive
correlation what happens as one of the
variables let's just talk about the
horizontal axis as that one gets bigger
and bigger in Vega as you get larger and
larger values what happens to the other
variable it also gets bigger right if
you think back a couple years we
actually gave in needs it's we call it
direct variation so a positive
correlation means you increase one let's
call it X you take one variable X maybe
its height temperature money that you
earn whatever as you increase that one
the other other one also increases this
is what we mean by a positive
correlation they go together that make
sense negative you can see there it
starts over here and there's a couple
down the bottom as well when you
increase one of areas like say the
horizontal one right you don't get the
same result for what happens the other
one it decreases you increase one you
decrease the other so an example that
the pump you're looking at years is the
longer people tend to wait the longer
customers tend to wait on like a you
know a customer helpline the more
minutes you wait what do you think the
relationship is to how satisfied you are
with the phone call yeah less satisfied
more minutes waiting less satisfied so
this is what we mean by a negative
correlation okay and then of course
within those we can talk about well is
it really really closely related or it's
just just sort of vaguely related or is
it kind of not related at all okay so
this is about questions 1 & 2 these are
the fundamentals of correlation we're
actually going to spend most of our time
today thinking about how do we find it
and I'm going to show you a couple of
ways to do that but before we get into
those nuts and bolts I want you to
understand a little better well what
does it mean so exercise 2 answers this
question what can you get out of a data
set if you know how it correlates now
really really important think just
numerically is that positive and
negative correlations the names refer to
the values that you get so you can get a
correlation that ranges between negative
1
which means it's a negative correlation
all the way to one so you're always
getting something in between those
boundaries okay
now you might think that a natural
letter to use for correlation would be
something like C except it turns out C's
been taken like there's the speed of
light and life y-intercepts and all that
kind of thing so you see it all for the
purposes of this lesson we're going to
use the letter R or drill down into a
little more later on about why we choose
that letter but for now what I'd love
you to indicate is correlation which
we're going to use the letter R to
indicate right it's kind of like our
relationship it's always going to be
between negative 1 and 1 if it's
negative you've got a negative
correlation if it's positive you've got
a positive correlation what kind of our
value would you expect for something
where there's no correlation we said
minus 1 is a negative correlation and 1
is a positive correlation where you
reckon top zero if you had a correlation
of zero what does this mean they're not
correlated at all does that make sense
ok so the more you are down this end the
closer you are to something like this ok
and the further the more negative you
are the course you are to something like
this